bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 durant
une heure comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi nous allons revenir sur
l'actualité du département aux premiers
invités de ce 26 septembre dominique
mocquard président d'a2m concept bonsoir
vous serez présent au salon de
l'automobile qui s'ouvre à paris ce week
end pour présenter vos dernières
innovations et vous verrez notamment
qu'on peut maintenant ouvrir sa voiture
avec un téléphone portable vous allez
nous expliquer comment cela fonctionne
bonsoir également à jacques pothier vous
êtes seul le directeur de l'institut des
langues études internationales à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et vous êtes avec nous car
c'est aujourd'hui la journée européenne
des langues étrangères alors justement
est ce que les français sont de bons
élèves
est ce qu'on apprend suffisamment et
surtout correctement de langue étrangère
en france
on y travaille sérieusement j'espère que
les dispositifs permettent d'améliorer
les choses c'est vrai que les français
ont la réputation n'est pas très bon en
langue étrangère
c'est peut-être lié à leur langue en
fait est assez caractéristique mais on
se donne les outils pour améliorer sa
merci bonne taille et vous nous
détailler tout à l'heure la façon dont
vous avez participé à cette journée
douce que l'institut a proposé des
animations notamment vers l'est les
étudiants nous allons débuter cette
édition comme chaque soir par un rappel
des principaux titres et cette première
en france un partenariat public privé
afin de réaliser une résidence pour
personnes âgées 7 à versailles l
établissement sera finalisé en 2016
depuis cet été
l épicerie sociale des l'encours géré
par la croix-rouge s'est dotée d'une
chambre froide pour fournir des denrées
fraîches aux bénéficiaires des
bénéficiaires de plus en plus nombreux
en ce mois de septembre
c'est aujourd'hui la journée européenne
des langues donc l'université de
versailles saint quentin a organisé une
journée de rencontre nous y reviendrons
vous l'avez compris sur ce plateau
et puis il n'ya pas du vin uniquement
dans les régions viticoles à elancourt
l'association des amis du passé
vendanges tous les ans cette année la
récolte permettra de réaliser 120 litres
à consommer avec modération bien entendu
on débute donc cette édition du 26
septembre avec adm concept entreprise de
saint quentin en yvelines qui sera
présente au salon de l'automobile porte
de versailles à paris
dominique mot car je le disais tout à
l'heure une introduction vous allez
présenter vos dernières innovations
notamment ce kit qui permet alors tout
d'abord d'ouvrir sa voiture avec son
téléphone portable et puis ensuite c'est
pour développer un système d'autopartage
vous allez nous expliquer tout ça alors
déjà comment ça fonctionne ce système
avec son téléphone portable on peut
piloter sa voiture alors si ce sont les
grandes nouveautés aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont en train de se mettre en place par
beaucoup de constructeurs automobiles
savait que l'usagé de la voiture est en
train de changer
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
plus dans le coup de coeur de sa voiture
beaucoup moins tout cas toute une
génération aujourd'hui se passe de la
voiture parce que les moyens de
transports aussi maintenant permettent
de se déplacer d'un point à un autre
assez facilement et le téléphone devient
en fin de compte un outil de
communication pour cette mobilité alors
qu'on passe par voler son téléphone
généralement on perd plus facilement ses
clés que ce téléphone étonnant donc
effectivement il est bien fait en tout
cas pour avoir maintenant pas mal de de
données en tout cas numérique et ses
données numériques maintenant il peut
les maîtres donc il peut recevoir
et puis après il peut les restituer
hélas ce qui est intéressant là
maintenant c'est que on s'est donc à
distance envoyer des données numériques
par du data c'est à dire que le
l'énergie demain aujourd'hui dans notre
civilisation ça sera du data sera plus
forcément du pétrole
on enverra des flux électrique de
différentes formes
ce data arrivera dans téléphone il
arrive effectivement avec une structure
qui est parfaitement numérisés et codé
qui fait que personne d'autre que la
personne qui l'a reçu
c'est exactement le code de ce message
et la partir de là quand vous arrivez
auprès de votre voiture déjà si c'est
votre propre voiture
votre voiture vous reconnaît et donc
comme elle vous reconnaît vous avez
l'ouverture des portes qui se met en
place et on peut imaginer après que vous
avez les réglage des rétroviseurs les
réglages du siège et et tutti quanti
et du coup c'est forcément très pratique
dans le cadre d'un auto partage de
location vers quelques images justement
du dispositif pendant que vous nous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne donc on
perd on peut ouvrir la voiture avec son
téléphone portable et ensuite on peut
éventuellement ouvrir une petite boîte
qui se trouve à l'intérieur une p-box et
à l'intérieur se trouve la clé physique
cette fois ci pour démarrer le véhicule
mais ça ça peut marcher dans le cas de
location de voiture d'auto partage aussi
par exemple te fais ce que comme je vous
l'avais expliqué la dernière fois
l'autopartage qui en fin de compte vous
voulez ma voiture je vous prête mes clés
et à partir de là vous allez pouvoir
ouvrir ma voiture pour la prendre
là maintenant on essaye là aussi
d'utiliser ces outils internet pour
faciliter et développer enfin contre
l'auto partage et la clé un code
identifiés sur le neiman de la voiture
qui fait par un transcodeur les deux
doivent communiquer ça vous pouvez pas
arriver avec une pièce métallique pour
vous redémarrez votre voiture ça
marchera pas il ya 7 de ce code qui
existe dans la clé donc il faut
absolument que ce soit la bonne clé est
toute la difficulté c'était ou mettre
cette clé parce que si vous la laissez à
l'intérieur de la voiture
vous savez qu'elle aimait et dans ces
cas là les portes se ferment pas donc il
faut que ce soit dans un endroit confiné
qui va permettre votre que de retrouver
là la clé alors que c'est cette petite
boîte qu'on a aperçu donc tout à l'heure
vous avez du voyage dont vous arrivez
avec votre téléphone vous avez reçu un
message comme quoi vous avez réservé
cette voiture vous passer effectivement
votre téléphone juste devant un badge
que l'adn concept donc réalise à
montigny le bretonneux
une fois que ce badge effet il a
identifié que c'était bien vous qui avez
réservé votre voiture est à l'intérieur
de la voiture sur le porte gobelet vous
avez effectivement ce petit produit qui
va venir effectivement s'ouvrir alors
c'est pas la maquette définitif le
démonstrateur qui sera sur le salon
douillet pas pu le démonter parce que
j'étais tout
mondial de l'automobile pour installer
tout ça c'est autre public à l'intérieur
vous trouvez effectivement les cartes
qui vont bien c'est à dire que les
cartes de différentes marques
d'électricité ou d'essence et puis vous
avez surtout la clé et quand vous
refermez en fin de compte ce gobelet
vous avez l'eau par leur le micro en fin
de compte toutes les fonctions de
l'autopartage qui vous permet de
démarrer
et quand vous avez fini votre votre
cycle d'orientation
vous remettez les clés dedans et vous
rebadgée à partir de là la voiture et la
voiture se ferment et le gobelet ce fan
donc on peut imaginer forcément ce
système sur des véhicules comme autolib
par exemple sur les systèmes qui
équipent qui équipe les véhicules en
autopartage sur sur paris vous allez me
présenter au salon de l'automobile sur
un véhicule d'une grande marque
est-ce que c'est fonctionnel ça va être
développée à grande échelle là c'est
encore un prototype vous en étau dans le
développement
alors je vous ai apporté quelques
produits pour voir un peu les
transitions donc là on a par exemple des
appuie tête de l'amm et bac de mercedes
qui sont fabriqués donc à montigny le
bretonneux dans l'usiné ldm que nous
avons racheté et nous avons créé un
support de ipad qui aujourd'hui chez
norauto mais vous pouvez le trouver
directement chez nous à 29 euros et qui
a cette mobilité en plus c'est à dire
qu'il tourne il s'enlève il se met sur
n'importe quel modèle de voiture donc ça
c'est un produit qui est présenté au
salon de l'auto qui est disponible qui
fait par vous avez développé on avait
des dispositifs
alors j'ai envoyé un autre système qui
est un système d'aérateurs on mettait
nos gps pour nos téléphones portables
sur un support à ventouse et donc là on
vient des clips et simplement la
rondelle des aérateurs et on vient
mettre notre petit système et à partir
de là vous venez mettre votre téléphone
portable et vous avez votre support
téléphone portable avec l'aérateur qui
fonctionne sous
comme vous le voyez c'est que à chaque
fois ces modèles là sont sur des modèles
spécifiques de constructeurs ou de gamme
de voitures on avait pas quelque chose
de transversales et la force de
réfléchir on a on a travaillé sur une
série limitée qu'on a fait pour la kia
qui étaient là qui est original et donc
on a mis sur le gobelet on a créé un
gobelet avec une couleur type orangina
et enfin quand on a créé des couleurs
dans cet environnement qui étaient noirs
et là on s'est dit on à un sujet assez
intéressant parce que le gobelet il est
transversale
les voitures au monde ont un porte
gobelets donc on va mettre de
l'électronique maintenant dans ce
gobelet et à partir de là on va pouvoir
transformer toutes les voitures du monde
avec un système en autopartage ou il
suffira d'acheter système que vous allez
présenter sur l'ensemble sur leur centre
et dès demain
touzov capable de le développer dès
demain si les constructeurs sont
intéressés et dès demain où nous on est
prêts ça y est on a on a vu les gens de
mauvais au donc le pôle de compétitivité
qui a qui a validé en fin de compte le
projet on a vu le l'association ravi
aussi kicking le risotto modèles
originaux envie qu'on avait vu avec
monsieur duchesne
il ya quelques semaines oseo excellence
validé on fait partie des 2000
entreprises aujourd'hui innovantes et là
le salon de l'auto ça va servir de
booste encore plus alors c'est un peu
exceptionnelle intensité très longues
années voire orange c'est à dire que la
société adhérents sur le stand orange
nous nous a demandé donc de créer un
concept car sur une opel ampera et donc
on a créé tout ceci tous ces éléments
dont je vous ai parlé en rajoutant en
plus ce qu'on a appelé le safety blague
qui le sauve t-bag éléments de sécurité
c'est quand vous avez votre voiture vous
faites attention à avoir aujourd'hui
l'éthylotest
le gilet et ainsi de suite mais quand
vous partagez la voiture il ya plus
personne pour vérifier la voiture donc
là c'est comme dans les grandes
boutiques vous avez le petit bouton
rouge là qui est mais en fin de compte
une petite couleur un bip bip si vous
sortez avec tout ça et effectivement on
va savoir que la voiture ne peut parler
anglais est donc un partage ans avoue
trouver le gilet l'éthylotest et vous
avez tout à l'intérieur ça sera présenté
sur le stand orange lac et boxe le
système nfc et tout cet ensemble sur le
pré l'emporter tout ce que vous avez
développé dont j'ai un rallye serait
pour vous et qu adm concept voilà
l'article la promotion est fait de tout
ce que vous allez pouvoir retrouver sur
le salon de l'automobile sur le stand
orange pour adm concept merci dominique
mocka rebond salon dire si le salon de
l'automobile pour le public c'est à
partir du 29 septembre jusqu'au 14
octobre et puis sachez que le lundi un
1er octobre sur téléfilm où seront sur
place pour une édition spéciale pour
découvrir l'ensemble des nouveautés des
constructeurs des équipementiers et qui
sont présents également sur le
département des yvelines je me tourne à
présent vers vous jacques potier
directeur de l'institut des langues à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
on va parler justement donc deux
journées des langues étrangères le 26
septembre on va en parler
un instant ça sera juste après ce
reportage consacré à la future résidence
pour personnes âgées de versailles une
résidence qui pour la première fois est
réalisée grâce à un partenariat public
et privé à valérie auribeau et guillaume
quand on se retrouve juste après sur le
plateau du 7-8
c'est une première dans les yvelines le
public et le privé investisse ensemble
dans un établissement pour personnes
âgées
le centre hospitalier de versailles la
clinique médicale de la porte verte et
la ville de versailles se sont réunis au
sein d'une société coopérative d'intérêt
collectif à laquelle s'ajoute une
structure solidaire entreprendre pour
humaniser la dépendance on as de nous
parle moi de 2000 actionnaires 1
quiconque il aujourd'hui en fait à
travers une épargne qui n'a pas encore
une fois qu'il n'a pas une vocation en
fait chanter des dividendes a bien
évidemment mais en fait les gens qui
investissent ils entendent effectivement
un résultat mais se permet de s'associer
à ce projet nécessite 20 millions
d'euros d'investissement assuré en
majorité par un prêt locatif social pour
compléter le budget une originalité les
versailles et ont la possibilité
d'investir en souscrivant des parts
sociales à hauteur de 20 euros
le chantier est en fait la rénovation de
l'établissement lépine providence
abandonné pour malfaçons et qui devait
accueillir 200 résidents un nombre qui
avait fait bondir la mairie de
versailles
ça nous a paru monstrueux
c'était une énorme maison de la
vulnérabilité et c'était contraire à ce
que la population nous renvoyer comme
demande et c'est de là quand ces divas
comment pouvons-nous répondre à cette
obligation de projet architectural mal
fini qui a besoin d'être repris et de
répondre aux besoins de la population
la structure proposera 112 places dont
quatre places d'hébergement temporaire
mais aussi 12 places d'accueil de jour
et 160 places de services soins
infirmiers à domicile dont 10
spécialisée alzheimer
l'ouverture de l'établissement lépine
providence est prévue début 2016